our view
on the view
that is amazing music
clueless ladies of the view say trump's
wife chappelle ended up black and blue
and then they had the gall to assume
we'd miss them in the bedroom
yesterday on the view also known as dumb
and dumber and dumber dumber
and incredibly somehow still even dumber
joy behar and sonny haasen tried their
best to link the chapel chappelle
attacked the donald
the fact that trump was out there saying
uh things like just knock the hell out
of them i promise you i'll pay for the
legal fees when he had a heckler i think
that trump unleashed
[Applause]
of course
the view forgets it was democrats like
like maxine waters who encouraged
confronting republicans at home and work
and told anti-cop protesters to get more
aggressive and let's not forget who
cheered the riots as forms of social
justice it wasn't magga so thank you joy
and sonny for the lamest attempt to
blame black on black violence on trump
since jesse smilet bought two nigerians
some maga hats
but
[Applause]
if you thought that was idiotic they
then tried to tackle abortion
women in the world have conducted sex
strikes in history in 2009 kenyan women
enforced a sex ban until political
infighting ceased within one week there
was a stable government
okay oh
we have more power than we think we have
and some of it could be right in the
bedroom
nonsense
if people weren't having sex in kenya
how'd we end up with president obama
an unhinged conspiracy frequency
i'm joking don't clap
my goodness people
and isn't it sexist isn't it sexist to
say women's best shot at changing the
world is with their bodies and not their
minds
on the other hand if it means the ladies
of the view are putting it on ice get
those women a nobel prize
joy behar promised to never have sex
with me i'd run out and buy a lottery
ticket
seriously joy behar suggesting a sex
strike that's like suggesting not to
serve steak at a peda convention
joy behar suggesting a sex strike that's
like jim jones threatening to take away
your kool-aid
joy behar suggesting a sex strike that's
like jim norton suggesting a sex strike
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i always hear about this gym
this sex strike thing is a solution for
problems i don't believe it ever works
or worked it's my great it's happened to
me before
it's been happening for 14 years uh
i woke up there was a bunch of women
around my bed with signs hell no
oh it's it's terrifying by the way if
there's a sex strike and you masturbate
are you a picket crosser
i'm glad you didn't say scab
you can always tell who's getting laid
they had a big rat in front of their
apartment
for the longest time i knew when i moved
to new york i never knew what that meant
like
when when you walk up the street and you
would see the grass you'd see the big
rat in front of a place it's a big
inflated rat if you've never seen it
before the unions will blow up an
inflatable rat and put it in front of a
place that's non-union or something uh
i've seen him on a golf course before
i've seen him a beheaded rat on like the
third tee i promise i asked what it was
about i didn't get it and the
my wife actually said do they do they
use union construction guys i said no
it's because that explains the rat i
didn't know what it was either it wasn't
around the bedroom thank god but
no i've never had rats in my bedroom
just crabs
wow this is
uh you should put the camera on
heather's face right now it's
just
absolutely disgusted with all of us
[Laughter]
okay that's all right you know cat um
yep
there's two view opinions here there's
the chappelle thing and the sex strike
thing pick which one you want to talk
about
what a tough choice
talk about blaming trump for that or joy
behind sex although okay i don't think
it's gonna work yeah like
i don't think the supreme court's going
to sit down and say you know what
we heard joy behar is not going to be
doing sex anymore
[Laughter]
now we got to rethink everything
i i mean it's great you know to be you
know it's okay to be you know passionate
about causes and fight for what you're
believing i'm just not sure this is
gonna be the thing that changes i think
she just wanted people to know she was
still having sex that could be it
you know so congrats on the sex yeah
rob you know the funny the irony of this
is a sex strike if it worked would
reduce pregnancies and thereby reduce
abortions
so maybe this is the pro-life answer for
democrats
i just think i think the issue is uh
that's the view is one of the shows
where it has a certain audience that's
all they watch to get their news from
right i personally think someone with
the name of joy and whoopi they'd be
really happy but they're not but uh but
i mean but they're spinning it just a
little bit like they said there's a
there was a a governor somewhere that
said he wanted to
not have interracial marriages that was
like at a press conference in 1960. they
forgot to mention that and he said and
all he said was this the state should
vote on it yes which is all they're
saying now they they so want to suppress
what could be democratic they won't let
you vote they will shut you down and
that's that's that's all they got yeah
and that in the economy yeah that's true
it's bad news heather last word to you
you could pick either topic either topic
i think it's a convenient excuse to
blame president trump for everything she
was blaming the the dave chappelle uh
that the violence on donald trump as
well i mean we can go back to the
gladiators uh 2 000 years ago they were
extremely violent yes they were and
maybe that's the cause right of the blm
riots the the police uh brutality i mean
you at some point in time you have to
stop blaming others and look in the
mirror but i do think uh if joy bayer i
am in agreement with all of the men on
set if she has a sex strike i don't
think that will change any opinions on
the supreme court decision
and i think we're going to end on that
note that was a very professional
assessment heather
i try yeah he did a great job
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else